hey guys i'm re-uploading the gideon
video from today
because i messed up i failed the source
where i originally heard this lore
theory from and that is 100
my bad i tried to contact the redditor
who made a post trying to
expose
me for uh plagiarism
on this um but they will not answer any
of my dms i genuinely love this theory
by practical meat and just wanted to
tell it to as many people as i could i'm
a little confused because the theory was
posted by r practical meat but the
threat of the plagiarism on my video was
made by someone by the name of anna
collagen v claiming that i used his
theory i'm not sure how that works on
reddit but credit to practical meat i
should have cited this work and i am
really sorry that i didn't and if you
look at my past videos i usually do but
any excuse that i make will be met with
hate and i've received a ton of it over
the past few hours and all i can say is
that i'm sorry i it will never happen
again
and i'll make sure to cite any sources
from
quite literally anywhere from now on
um
on where i hear anything from and while
i don't think harassment is okay i
understand why he and his community are
upset in my eyes it's lore of elden ring
we're just trying to tell a story of a
game that we all [ __ ] love i use my
own words in this video for 95 of it and
i failed to cite the five percent that i
did not and that's completely on me but
people will see it how they want to see
it so i'm sorry it will not happen again
and enjoy the video
we first encounter gideon off near at
the round table hold where he's sort of
dismissive of us as a tarnished and
reminds us that we are no more than just
a guest of the round table allow me a
word of advice
as your senior
you are a mere visitor to the round
table nothing more
a house guest
yet to earn their keep
remember your place
newcomer until we obtain a great rune
and hear from the two fingers where he
finally recognizes us stating then i bid
you welcome
as a true member of the round table
knowing this it makes it quite confusing
as to why he tries to stop us from
reaching the urge to become the elden
lord since he clearly intends for us to
hunt down the demigods and obtain great
runes in the pursuit of becoming elden
lord once we prove ourselves to him
after defeating godric gideon opens up
giving us backstories and locations of
the other rune bearers that he's aware
and knowledgeable of which you would
think by giving us this information
rewarding us when we find more
information about rune bearers that even
he wasn't aware of that this is what he
wants and encourages us to keep pursuing
the great runes you would also think
that my percentage of actual subscribers
of people who watch my videos here on
youtube would be higher than four
percent actually i really don't know why
you would think that since this is a
very new channel in fact the channel has
been doing amazing lately so thank you
all very much it also helps me put food
on the table and feed my dog look how
cute she is i'm totally not trying to
make you feel bad for not subscribing
yet alright i'll stop let's get into the
video we know that gideon off near is
looking for access to the realm of the
halo tree how do we know this well we
know he had the village of the albanoric
slaughtered in order to retrieve part of
the secret halagtree medallion we know
this from nafeli lou gideon's adoptive
daughter where we meet her in this
village disgusted by what she's found we
help her defeat an omen killer and when
we get back to the round table we hear
that gideon has cast her aside as her
daughter and she can be found upset in
the basement of the round table
contemplating how gideon would do
something so cruel as to slaughter an
entire village and i
can no longer trust him father to think
he'd ordered his men to enact such
tragedy
where is the justice he departs in that
he once told me that if he became elder
lord
he would never allow the downtrodden to
be cheated ever again
was he simply lying to me
gideon also killed latina's wolf lobo to
attempt to get her part of the secret
medallion of the haleg tree she refers
to him as the all-hearing brute and says
that she doesn't know where the secret
medallion is
i told the all-hearing boot that i
possess no such medallion or have you
come to take more from me
was my other half not enough and after
we obtain half of the medallion
returning to the round table causes the
player to spawn in an alternate version
of the round table where gideon's
bodyguard attempts to kill you
presumably to take this medallion after
this gideon seems to deflect the
responsibility for this happening and
claims that the bodyguard acted alone
my apologies for that nasty business
and got rather ahead of himself it seems
as his master
i'd like to express my regret
but now
and she is slain and gone
finished forevermore and in my opinion
this is where gideon starts to lie his
ass off this brings up a lot of
questions for me if he wanted access to
the heilig tree most likely to kill
melania or mikola to steal their great
room why wouldn't he just attack the
other rune bearers that he was aware of
like godric reichardt morgot ranala or
radon maybe he didn't want to fight them
himself but instead uses you the tarnish
to do it for him why would he have the
bodyguard attack us and not let us keep
half the medallion to track down and
kill melania for the great room that he
seems to want at this point with that in
mind it's pretty clear that this great
rune in particular melania and mikolas
is of higher value to gideon than the
others or he wanted to prevent anyone
from being able to access this region
ensuring that it remains hidden and shut
away so at this point we can assume
gideon's goals are one ensure that the
demigods are slaughtered or ensure that
the great runes one or two or all of
them are assembled that part's pretty
unclear or two ensure that no one
accesses the hollow tree region or he
wants to obtain something in the halak
tree region for himself he also claims
that he wants to become elden lord
despite not attempting to travel to any
of the rune bearers to take the runes
himself again probably excluding mykola
or melania if he did want to reach the
hollow tree region so if this is true
and he intended to become elden lord
without obtaining great runes directly
from the demigods he likely always
intended to have one tarnish gather them
for him and then to just eventually take
them from the tarnished however this is
not what we see when we fight gideon
when we do fight gideon he says this
i knew you'd come to stand before the
elden ring
to become elden lord
what a sad state of affairs
i commend your spirit but alas
none shall take the throne
queen america has high hopes for us
that we continue to struggle
what we can take from this is that one
he is working or believes that he is
working on america's behalf and two he
does not intend to become elden lord
himself only to prevent others from
becoming elden lord so we really don't
know what gideon has experienced all the
way up to this point when we face him
it's entirely possible that he has
somehow encountered america between your
previous encounters with gideon and your
battle with him and no longer wishes to
become elden lord or it's possible that
he's always felt this way and has
manipulated others as to his true
intentions either way we can assume that
he's legitimately trying to assist
america as he has no reason to deceive
you anymore as he's trying to kill you
and given this vast wealth of
information and experience that he has
he likely isn't being tricked or
misinformed as to what queen america
wants when we read guinean's armor set
it says that knowledge begins with the
recognition of one's ignorance the
realization that the search for
knowledge is unending but when gideon
glimpsed into the will of queen america
he shuddered in fear at the end that
should not be to me this sounds like
gideon was always working for america
slash ratagon the whole time queen
america and radagon are two halves of
the same entity one shattering the ring
and the other wants to prepare it i
think we can assume that gideon is
working for the half that wants to
repair it since he wants us to struggle
for eternity america and ratagon are the
vessel for the elden ring and a tool of
the greater will to control the lands
between the herd tree is a manifestation
of the greater will a life form that
feeds on struggle every tomb or dungeon
in the game ends with this visual of her
tree roots entangled with corpses a
shattered elden ring paves the way for
the urgery to be destroyed and a new
outer god to take control a repaired
elden ring ensures that america remains
in control with the urgery intact so an
eternity of struggle can take place with
the resulting corpses of the struggle
beating the herd tree so if gideon
really does intend to help repair the
elden ring then this statement about
america's hopes in eternity of struggle
must allude to the urgery's continued
feasting of the results of war
and battle so how does america continue
this struggle so that they can keep
feeding what the herd tree needs she
sends off the tarnish to outside the
lands between to live and die struggling
so that they can become stronger but she
always planned for them to end up coming
back this is what gideon is referring to
when he says queen america has high
hopes for us that we continue to
struggle onto eternity i believe that
gideon obtained the knowledge of queen
america's plan and that's why it seems
like he takes a 180 on what we thought
he wanted to do or he was manipulated by
queen america we just don't know for
sure we can assume however that queen
america doesn't want us to become elden
lord but does want us to try it's all
about the struggle it's all about the
suffering and the failing that feeds the
urgery and thus the greater will america
shattered the elden ring in defiance of
the greater will ratagon tried to repair
it because he is still loyal to the
greater will this is why america wants
no one to become elden lord by keeping
the ring shattered she keeps the greater
will weakened hence all the dead fingers
at the divine towers as for gideon he
remarked that a man cannot kill a god
upon his defeat this is referring to the
greater will not america or ratagon he
believes that the player must eventually
be stopped to prevent the elden ring
from being repaired and finally the
greater will itself attacks you in the
form of its avatar the elden beast for
the sole reason of getting a hold of the
runes you have collected and repaired
for it it doesn't want you to become
elden lord as you wouldn't be a puppet
lord like ratagon was you would have
your own free will so it tries to kill
you in order to get the runes and then
find another that can replace ratagon
this is why when you kill the elden
beasts you have effectively killed the
greater will which is why it says god
slain upon its defeat finally depending
on the ending that you choose you can
mend the elden ring yourself you can
give it to ronnie or just destroy
everything with the three fingers in the
flame of frenzy becoming the lord of
chaos so just know when you're out there
playing the game and dying over and over
again to some boss that you're
struggling with you are inevitably
feeding the erd tree and in my opinion
that should piss you off more to
eventually get to the ending where you
can break this cycle and be rid of the
earth tree or you can choose to keep it
going the ending is completely up to you
that's why i love these games man
they're freaking awesome and i have to
preface this in every video all of this
is speculation we aren't ever meant to
know everything exactly in the world of
elden ring which is why it's so much fun
to come up with theories as to what we
think the story is so discuss calmly
down in the comments of what you think
thank you all for watching the video and
i will see you in the next video take
care
you